on ne bouge pas dans un génial ça va
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bon alors ça s'appelle interview
technicolor donc c'est très simple c'est
que pendant la réponse à la question
vous allez être de la couleur
de la question pendant la réponse de la
couleur de la question
c'est le jeu pendant la réponse vous m
de largeur cette question christelle
qu'est ce qui vous rend vert de rage
bon il aux trucs et la jalousie
qu'est ce qui vous rend rouge de honte
l'habite yves qu'est ce qui vous rend
bleus de peur
les monstres la nuit les monstres à
dévoyer démence la nuit je trouve faut
arrêter vos maîtres du produit faut
mettre du produit
c'est quand que tu vois de trois ans
serait dans ta chance et il y en a des
millions à la gamme
ils sont maîtres
chez nous et c'est drôle
qu'est-ce que des bons sens rien
qu'est ce qui vous rend rose de bonheur
l'amour
en ébauche banding
[Musique]
laurent baffie ne sera pas là la semaine
prochaine bien alors ces quatre
questions
qu'est ce qui vous rend vers d'orage
pédophilie ce
touriste sexuel
qu'est ce qui vous rend rouge de honte
quand je me marre en scène c'est à dire
quand moi même un vrai spectacle je suis
pris par le rire d'un spectateur une
étude ac ou pas je vous marrez
l'agéroute qu'est ce qui peut vous
rendre bleus de peur
est reconnue dans la rue à part un
raconteur d'histoires kim entreprend et
je vous parle d'une histoire arrivée
c'est à dire beaubourg odéon avec un mec
alors c'est un type qui rentre dans un
café il était au barca alors l'autre
histoire et offert six matches et voilà
c'est ma terreur qu'est-ce qui
voudraient enfin des pêcheurs
qu'est ce qui vous rend rose de bonheur
mon petit garçon tmz
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voilà et voilà et voilà pas là clair
attention naomi est parti parce que
alors monsieur thériault
excusez moi qu'est ce qui vous fait rire
jaune
ici oui vous aimez pas le cynisme assez
marrant
ça vous ça oui ça me rend malade tousse
et c'est triste jour ça ouais l'ironie
c'est drôle d'ironie ce monde d'accord
qu'est ce qui vous rend verte d'orage
l'utilisation de l'ignorance des gens à
des fins douteuses ah ouais ouais les
médaille miraculeuse tout ça ouais entre
autres les guérisseurs les mages les
de télévision
quoi par exemple
extremis qu'est ce qui vous rend rouge
de honte ben ça voilà le résultat de
l'utilisation de l'ignorance des gens et
bleu de peur qu est-ce qui vous pour en
bleu de peu
et les requins aller vers eux et
là tout à l'heure c'est non ah si je
gère c'est pourquoi parce que un peu
chagriné justement parce que c'est sympa
parce que c'est une bonne émission de
s'allonger énorme il a dû vous racontez
votre jules dont je dirais non la
semaine prochaine ça s'est bien passé
pour lui bien qu est ce qui vous rend
rose de bonheur ce à quoi
à
d'accord donc tout le monde est encore
plus accros non attention ne bouge pas
mal jingle acabit technicolor ne bouge
pas pendant le jingle
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
qu'est ce qui vous rend vert de rage
l'intolérance qu'est ce qui vous rend
rouge de honte
la maladresse qu'est ce qui vous rend
bleus de peur
la violence
qu'est ce qui vous rend rose de bonheur
l'amour qu'est ce qui vous fait rire
jaune
tous les excès qu'est-ce qui vous grise
quelquefois hélas la victoire on ne
bouge pas tant dans le team
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
moi
[Applaudissements]
mais pour bassirou voilà
je terminais termine je referai plus
c'est sûr bien alors on va faire une
petite interview technicolor par exemple
qu'est ce qui vous rend vert de rage
c'est pas les trucs quand c'est grave un
jeune âge mais l'air pas trop si un seul
matériel style je cherche des raisons
que je touche je cherche d une paire de
chaussettes voix ouais et je la trouve
pas oui oui c'est bien rangée alors je
regardais je signale
trois garçons ensemble et que vraiment
le matin c'est vrai que c'est un peu le
bordel à présent je peux vraiment
m'énerver roman
benson salon n'importe quoi
herman je suis de plus en plus en retard
et j'aime pas ça oui c'est sûr qu'est ce
qui vous rend bleus de peur bleue de
peur là la moto dernièrement justement
pour une émission j'avais deux émissions
et on envoyait un schéma pas si c'était
pas pour une moto taxi way ces derniers
le chauffeur pour pour me faire plaisir
tu vois il allait souvent dans les
embouteillages moi ça me faisait passer
je gueulais lui croyais que j'étais
content
bien
qu est ce qui vous rend rouge de honte
non non non vous de votre nom non gérés
non rien
non non
jamais rien non je paye à votre mère qui
vient chez vous alors embrassé soit ses
enfants et tous comment ça va les
petites ça il ya un godemiché sur la
table de nuit ça vaut mais ça m'est
arrivé j'ai carouge normes
et aux parfums je vois tu vois ça aurait
parlé de couy
retrouvés
qu'est ce qui vous rend rose de bonheur
rose de bonheur ben j'aime bien là on
pousse à la période approche est bien un
petit apéro comme ça chez moi dans le
sud qui rosé comme sa petite herbe
connaît un petit spigaou chatouille un
peu là
ils ont le sens du bonheur ces gens là
qu'est ce qui vous fait rire jaune ya
corti times a raconté une blague dans
les cours jerry pourra faire plaisir
ouais
titoff qu'est-ce qui vous grise l'amitié
vraiment
dans l'amitié l'amitié et par tous
les bouts ting
tings
[Musique]
alors ce soir s'ils arrêtent tout le
monde bouge chez portnawak non mais je
ne crois pas ça ouais là que des
révolutionnaires beigbeder julie baffie
heureusement que nos amis tchèques sont
respectueux du règlement alors là c'est
une révolution de velours
exactement
serge july ce qui vous rend vert de rage
moi qui suis pas du tout pour
l'interdiction de quoi que ce soit en
particulier pas de loft story m'enfin
voyez seulement un peu vers le rêve
encore expliqué que votre chroniqueur
télévision david dufresne il a expliqué
comme daniel schneidermann dans le monde
d'ailleurs au départ est trouvé ça
formidable il ya une semaine après ils
ont commencé à mettre un peu aimée parce
que un journal
qui fait par des journalistes ouais
c'est pluriel ouais donc vous ça vous
énerve plus que david dufresne - oui
voilà mais c'est le côté vous savez dans
cette affaire-là ça me rappelle une
pièce que vous devez connaître est une
très belle pièce de théâtre qui
s'appelle la dispute de marivaux face au
18e et il ya deux aristocrates qui
s'interroge sur l'amour c'est comment ça
se passe l'infidélité entre les gens
commencent à nay et il dit si il décide
de dire bon on va voir on va faire un
exercice on va prendre quatre jeunes
gens deux filles deux garçons ça se
passe au xviiie siècle deux jeunes
filles deux jeunes garçons qui n'ont eu
aucune histoire on va les faire élevé
par des serviteurs qui n'ont absolument
aucun contact et puis quand ils seront
grands adolescents
ben on verra ce qui se passera ce qui se
passe il se passe une tragédie et ça
fait penser à sa différence c'est que
c'est marivaux qui écrit alors que la
ccem arrivons qui écrit oui là il n'y a
pas de scénario dialogues
et l'om inquiet créer une structure mais
c'est terrible cette histoire parce que
quand libération fait sa une avec love
story convenable voilà 15 % de plus donc
que les parce que c'est une vieille d'un
point de vue sociologique c'est une des
questions les plus passionnantes qui
soit moi je je remercie m6 d'avoir fait
cette émission pourquoi alors que je
suis vert de rage pourquoi mais parce
que c'est le plus grand débat qu'ont eu
sur la télévision va être très longtemps
donc été très bien c'était la der la der
de benghazi sur aziz oui finalement sa
version qui veut être connu et en menant
est pourquoi pour être connu ouais bah
oui non toi public a écrit un livre pour
être comme on est dans une émission de
télévision c'est en gros c'est une
vision du paradis terrestre ce loft à la
porte de la chapelle
vision du paradis terrestre puisqu'on
mais pas loin d'ici vous savez on
pourrait y aller l'addition pourrait y
aller d'ailleurs et d'à côté allez on la
tour
dans ce paradis terrestre selon les pays
le des principales c'est un vendre son
âme pour passer à la télévision mais
préserve vraiment de quoi pour passer à
la télévision on est dans une émission
de télévision donc comme on le sait donc
ça ça nous touche tous en fait vous faut
vous regardez love story n'a au midem un
départ complètement excusable j'ai
jamais alors là vous pouvez regarder
château story
bien qu est ce qui vous rend rouge de
route
c'est de m'être trompé
en fait les erreurs y compris dans des
papiers c'est un fait on a parlé la
dernière fois va pas recommencer oui
mais ça mais c'est terrible on a fait le
moteur la dernière fois ci mais voilà ça
c'est bruay en artois le notaire soit on
n'arrête pas de rire à chaque fois mais
voilà c'est le problème des épisodes
voilà ce qu'ils ont raté les saisons
précédentes tant pis pour eux qu'est ce
qu'ils vont en bleu de peur
je peux souffler oui dix mois que la
fonte de la calotte polaire le
réchauffement mais voilà fait merci
fonelle je vous en prie si ça monte d'un
mètre ouais ça va quand même est
terrible c'est ça a été terrible nous
savons en bleu de peur oui bafa c'est
pas pour demain ne pas mieux mais c'est
comme j'ai une petite fille formidable
absolument génial qu'il soit nbi ouais
donc
qu'est ce qu'ils vont en rose de bonheur
cette petite fille et sa mère
qu'est ce qui vous fait rire jaune
blake et mortimer louis nicollin a
offert une interview de technicolor à
gauche fatigue
[Applaudissements]
moi
très simple qui essaient technicolor
qu'est ce qui vous rend louis nicollin
vert de rage vert de rage des fêtes
qu'est ce qui vous rend rouge de honte
quand je parle mal
des gros mots ouais pareil comme sur le
banc de touche bayer surtout à la télé
ça va moi pour le moment c'est bien ce
qu'est ce qui vous rend bleus de peur
de descendre en d2 ah oui mais ça s'est
réglé ça sapeurs veillard et prochaine
qu'est ce qui vous rend rose de bonheur
rouge de bonheur ouais de regagner la
coupe de france
on ne bouge pas pendant les ting âge on
ne bouge pas pendant le singer
[Applaudissements]
qu'est ce qui vous rend vert de rage
l'ennui est franchie way bleu de peur
de devoir parler devant des gens que je
connais pas
c'est vrai ce qui vous rend rose de
bonheur
le sexe
est ce qui vous fait rire jaune les gens
fils
tendance à se rabaisser pour montrer à
quel point ils sont superbes à
la fausse modestie ni fausse modestie
pardon ah oui d'accord ce qui vous rend
rouge de honte
d'être mal coiffée quand je vais
réflexion
ne bouge pas pendant le ténia
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
qu'est ce qui vous rend vert de rage
vert de rage
la séparation de jennifer de joie parce
que la star academy ça m'a rendu malade
non non non mais je crois qu'il faut pas
rigoler avec ça parce que qu'est-ce qui
vous rend rouge de honte
bue je
bats c'est noël et je vais faire un truc
que je vais regretter je sais mon fils
veut que je lui achète un disque de
roméo et juliette alors ouais enfin que
j ai cherché en guinée ont déjà qu'est
ce qui vous rend bleus de peur bleue de
peur que campoli d'hermann m'appelle
pour me dire passe demain au bureau la
géorgie qu'est ce que j'ai fait comme
conneries
qu'est ce que j'ai dit qu'il fallait pas
dire à qui j'ai dit bonjour qu'il
fallait pas qu'est ce qui vous rend rose
le bonheur
d'être là ce soir sera et des gens qu'on
respecte depuis des années maintenant et
les robes à nicolas hulot cachemire
c'est fait
qu'est ce qui vous fait rire jaune
jackie chan ah ouais
touche pas
qu'est ce qui vous rend vert de rage
la mauvaise foi
qu'est ce qui vous rend rouge de route
mon orgueil
qu'est ce qui vous rend bluster
les premiers trous d'air
qu'est ce qui vous rend rose de bonheur
d'amour
qu'est ce qui vous fait rire jaune
l'hypocrisie politique
veut servir en ce moment un petit peu
[Applaudissements]
qu'est ce qui vous rend verte de rage à
l'injustice
du gauche à la télévision
qu'est ce qui vous rend rouge de honte
lundi
qu'est ce qui vous rend bleus de peu
mardi
j'ai peur toujours
pour des gens que j'aime pour mes
enfants
qu'est ce qui vous rend rose de bonheur
un bon bain et le lit
ce qui vous fait rire jaune quand je me
réveille le matin et je me regarde dans
le miroir et je vois ce que je déteste
la vieillesse et je vois une tente que
je détestais quand j'étais petit qui
avait des longues longues et tout le
monde quand j'étais petit on tout le
monde toute la famille j'ai peur latente
l'attend betty vient lui parler elle
touchait tout le temps elle était comme
ça elle avait une bouche comme ça et je
me vois dans le miroir et j'ai eus
ensemble chaque jour plus qu'est ce qui
vous fait broyer du noir
on pensait que peut-être je n'aurai plus
jamais du travail
kaunas et les charlots en france les
charlots et est assez ils sont marrants
bas s'entraideront me font rire jaune
[Applaudissements]
qu'est ce qui vous rend vert de rage
quand je vois la photo de charron
sharon stone
qu'est ce qui vous rend rouge de honte
vous donc
quand je vois l'indifférence de la
communauté internationale à l'égard de
ce qui se passe en palestine en ce
moment qu'est ce qu'ils vont en bleu de
peur
le docteur quand j'ai des cauchemars la
nuit que je vois chalon dans mon
cauchemar
qu'est ce qui vous rend rose de bonheur
quand elle a trouvé une solution un
conflit quand on était à jérusalem quand
on a pu signer un accord de paix
quand on a mis fin à une guerre terrible
au mozambique
qu'est ce qui vous fait rire jaune ce
qui me fait rire jaune ou parfois
la peur dans cette haine potes rappeurs
[Applaudissements]
qu'est ce qui vous rend vert de rage
pour rester sur le registre de ce que
nous disions ce qui me rend vers de rage
s'est laissé les bobos qui ont voté
laguiller besancenot premier tour parce
que qu'un qu'un syndicaliste qu'un
employé du crédit lyonnais qui gagne 12
mille balles par mois votre laguiller je
comprends qu'un postier vote besancenot
je comprends mais que des bourgeois
friqués et j'en connais plein autour de
moi votre laguiller parce qu'il a trouvé
mouvante et votre besancenot parce qu'il
le trouve sympa ça je trouve ça nul et
on n'en serait pas là où nous sommes
jospin serait au second tour s'il n'y
avait pas eu ça donc ça c'est vrai que
ça me rend vers d'orge qu'est ce qui
vous rend rouge de honte la presse
internationale la presse étrangère
depuis dimanche dernier c'est à dire le
spectacle que nous donnons la le fait
que nous soyons la risée du monde entier
ont donné des leçons aux autrichiens
cause de lieder ont donné des leçons à
aux italiens cause à cause de berlusconi
et on se retrouve avec le pire des trois
sacres à dire le pet et le pire pourquoi
hein parce que c'est le plus fashion et
deux parce que c'est le plus gros test
parce qu'en plus il est plus ridicule
donc ça en effet ça me rend comment vu
rouge de rôle de rampe
[Applaudissements]
qu'est ce qui vous rend bleus de peur
c'est que le front national
on verra son score mais qu'il
n'introduisait en france le sale venin
de la haine de la violence et de la
guerre civile parce que ça aussi je
crois qu'il faut le dire aux gens qui
nous écoutent le il se présente sous le
drapeau de la lutte contre l'insécurité
partout où ils sont allés dans toutes
les mairies qu'ils ont géré ils ont pas
eu moins d'insécurité ils ont eu plus
d'insécurité ils ont mis en place des
milices privées moi je me rappelle à
vitrolles j'étais allé avec konopnicki
on avait fait un film à vitrolles qui
s'appelait bienvenue à vitrolles et on
avait vu par exemple se mettre en place
le dps qui est une milice privée d'une
milice privée du front national une
police parallèle et ça à la police
parallèle en france quand c'est
vitrolles c'est déjà très grave mais si
ça devait venir si le front national
fort de son succès
se croyant tout permis venait à
multiplier ce genre de choses alors là
je crois que nous serions au bord de
troubles très grave de grande violence à
val fourré comme vous disiez tout à
l'heure et ailleurs et ça c'est vrai que
ça me fout les jetons cette espèce de
culture de la haine que le front
national est en train d'en produire en
france
ce qui vous rend rose de bonheur ce qui
me rendrait rose de bonheur ses 6 et 10%
dimanche prochain c'est à dire si
je suis
là c'est même plus à ariel là je suis
légèrement obsédé et il faut que le pen
retourne dans sa boîte un son score en
france c'est 10% ces 15% c'est pas plus
il faut qu'ils retournent au 10 ou 15%
et là bas on serait tous heureux on fera
la fête
ce qui vous fait rire jaune
quand je vois comme l'autre jour chez
séguillon le pen qui se drape dans le
drapeau de la france et de la république
alors que c'est le contraire par exemple
voilà l'amour de la france moi je crois
que le front national c'est le front
antinational c'est à dire chaque fois
qu'il y a dans le monde un parti un
groupe qui est la france
le pen s'y rallient par exemple en
belgique est un parti qui s'appelle le
vlaams blok le vlaams blok ya des trucs
qui fait c'est qu'à la frontière entre
la belgique et la france en flandre il
supprime les panneaux français il
supprime lille les panneaux de
signalisation
bon c'est un palace est un parti anti
français c'est l'allié de le pen c'est
avec ça qu'ils fait cause commune au
parlement européen alors tout ça
quand j'entends dire que le pen est un
thème la france par exemple ça me fait
rire et ça me fait rire très jaune et
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de inler
titube abonnez vous il m'était
impossible ou